the UN Chief has called on Russia and
Ukraine to extend a deal that allows
Kiev to export green Antonio Gutierrez
wants obstacles removed to allow for the
exports of Russian food and fertilizer
shipments from Ukraine have resumed
seven ships have already left Ukrainian
ports since the grain Corridor reopened
Moscow had suspended its involvement in
the U.N broker deal over the weekend
after accusing Kiev of attacking its
Fleet in the Black Sea well let's speak
to us at big he's joining us live from
michalaf so what's the latest after that
yesterday's change to the grain deal
well we understand that from at least
from Russian sources that they're saying
that the shipments have been normalized
but Ukrainian president of vloginess
come out and said that Russia's fires
cruise missiles over the airspace over
that Corridor that grain Corridor uh
airstrikes that and missiles are on
their way to hit Ukrainian targets now
Ukraine has denied that they have used
those three ports and that Corridor that
are part of this deal to Target Russia
but Russia doesn't believe that their
their warship was attacked by drone and
they said that Ukraine has been using
those ports and that grain Corridor now
Russia says that they've come back to
the deal because they've been given
guarantees that the officials in
tortilla have said that they've also
been given verbal and written guarantees
that made Russia come back to it not
from the Ukrainian side while they're
saying they haven't said anything new
that wasn't in the initial deal now this
deal is set to run out at the later this
month and Russia is saying that there's
no guarantee that it will be extended
but the ukrainians come complaints still
remain they're saying that Russia
continues to fire
missiles and Rockets and airstrikes at
their vital infrastructure that is
causing real damage to the energy Supply
here there's blackouts around the
country and some some regions are
setting up mobile Heating units in the
leader to Winter and just on that late
earlier early this morning in curvary
just north of here there was a drone
strike on an emphasis on a vital
infrastructure and they've had
electricity and water shortages so
that's the complaint from the ukrainians
that although that this grain Corridor
and this initiative Russia has rejoined
it and they're allowed to export this
grain but the war continues the
airstrikes on vital infrastructure in
Ukraine continuing the lead-up to Winter
sir thank you very much indeed that's
Assad bringing this up to date from
mikalayov